beating hatred in the internal realm
yeah is the hottest boss
battle in life and in the video game man
I I'm not sure it's possible but it's I
do make progress so then I'm like okay
I'm making progress
maybe if I just tweak that Paragon board
a little
more I can do it could just dodge a few
more waves
MH can do it well the simulation is
created for the purpose of figuring out
if it can be done and you're just a cog
in that simulation in the machine of the
simulation yeah it might
be I I I I I have a feeling that at
least I
think it's doable it's doable yes mhm
well that's the human Spirit right there
to believe yeah I mean it did prompt me
to think about just hate in general
which is you know want to be careful of
one of those things where you wish for
something that sounds
good but but if you get it it's actually
a dystopian situation so you know you
could sort of run a sort of
uh hypothesis of like if you wish for
World Peace sounds good MH but how's it
enforced and and at what cost is is it
what at what cost Eternal peace it might
actually be worse to have eternal peace
because of what that would entail the
suppression of
everyone it might be the suppression of
progress it might be an oied society
that never changes mhm one I'm saying is
that there is an
argument
that you you that if that if you wish
for no war you should be careful what
you wish
for because what's required in order for
there to be
Noble might be worse than a little war
yeah the things we consider to be flaws
of human civilization might be
unnecessary components for whatever
optimal looks
like